a New Jersey man found an innovative way
to give back to health care workers
after five of his family members five
were diagnosed with the corona virus
Javed Ali is his name he says he learned
face masks are irritating some health
care workers ears so what did he do he
taught himself how to use a 3d printer
to print a solution in just weeks he
made so-called ear savers to keep the
masks tied behind the doctors and nurses
heads using a template that he found
online so they take the strain off the
ears and they feature messages like stay
strong and hero at work as a result of
kind of feeling powerless you know over
not being able to do anything you know
about the corona virus and the situation
at hand and being stuck at home I felt
like I needed to do something
he told CBS this morning he's already
donated 50 and he's making even more so
Tony I say you go Javed Ali that's great
yeah it's a wonderful thing those
frontline workers they were they really
need those you know in this in the
civilian world the ones that go over
your your ears though I think might be a
little bit better cuz you can call them
hair savers I get that kink back there
it's like hat head from back when I was
a kid but no it's a wonderful gesture
they definitely need them and I love the
the sayings on the back too hero at work
that really sums it up